thank you Mark for the introduction my
name is Tony Chen and I'm a six-year PC
student in March lab biomedics and
experts in manipulation lab and today I
want to talk about designing robotic
grippers for interaction with real world
environments
so a little bit teaser here is robots
well we have robots around for 50 60 70
years now all the way from the beginning
in 1966 here at the shaky we always have
platforms that can start with
observation right we see what
environment we want to deploy the robot
scene in this case it's a hallway it's a
cluttered room and we're equipping these
robots with with Mobility with a form of
mobility in this case let's look at
let's have a bunch of sensors on there
see what's uh what obstacles in the way
as we as a technology for certain
robotic platforms mature more and more
then we started looking into how do we
make these robots more useful then it
comes to manipulation so this is a
screenshot of the New Boston Dynamics
Atlas video that released a couple days
ago amazing like a robot platform can
the parkour and a lot of amazing
Mobility things but now let's then the
next step is let's try to put a grip
around there let's actually have it to
manipulate have a capability to
manipulate
so what is manipulation manipulation is
the way for the capability to give
capability to the robot to be able to
forcefully interact with this
environment whether that be the real
world environment or another object so
today since I only have 20 minutes I
want to focus down two projects that
worked on here
um on two other platform robotic
platforms one is a drone the other one
is a Planetary Exploration robot and
both of these in both cases observation
and Mobility they do pretty well
especially for drone it's amazing
parallel versatility in terms of
observing and taking videos and stuff
like that but how do we add the
capability to manipulate to these
robotic platforms
so first let's talk about drones
so aerial grasping this work is uh done
with me and a collaborator Kenneth right
here and is founded by Air Force
and require others drones really have a
lot of good versatility it as a robotic
platform but right now it's still very
limiting in what interaction can have
with the real world environment so this
is sort of a state of the art what can
drones do but what can nature do what
has Nature has been doing for millions
of years at this point flying creatures
such as Eagle can catch a fish out of
the water like this so when and how can
we equip drones right now with
technology that allows us to do
something similar to this or work
towards it
the challenging thing about aerial
grasping is that we have a drone like
this you want to hit something mid-air
it's going to impart a large angular and
linear disturbance to the system then
how to develop control strategies that
can actually compensate for this and
make sure that drone doesn't crash make
sure that it's at the right velocity or
position profile to be able to capture
the target all this is to be seen
so where do we start designing any
gripper to design any gripper to design
anything to use in robots we always
start with Dynamics so here we actually
employ a very very simple
quadrature Dynamics a quad other Dynamic
model
where you know the
Fe here and then Tau C is the input
force and torque due to the Collision
and this can sort of be these are
related to each other through the Drone
geometry
and uh the F subscript U and tell you
here is basically the Drone controller
input what force and torque is desired
and through a simple feedback policy and
that is the best case approximation we
can say okay they're related to the
roller speed because that's all in all
that's what you're controlling is the
four rotors on the Drone
then through the simplification then we
can say Okay so this problem turned into
the changing linear angular momentum
resulted from this Collision
so sure now we have these equations how
do we make it useful because we're using
these Dynamics to inform our gripper
mechanics design
what does that mean that means that from
these two equations what we can get we
want to reduce the magnitude of this
force and reducing the interval as short
as possible
more concretely
what does that mean for gripper design
is that first one motivates a compliance
the use of compliance and friction to
dissipate energy during the collision
and the second part motivates a fast
acting gripper so the fast acting
gripper also has advantage of
error grasping that your target is now
bouncing out of your grasp
so now we have these lessons we're
trying to design around
and the three main goals we identify as
the mean point for this error grasper is
one we want to minimize the overall
weight and inertia because the Drone
payload is very limited two we want to
maximize the allowable maximum velocity
difference between the two target at the
two drones and three we want to minimize
torque applied after the capture so the
Drone can remain safe after even after
the capturing
so here's a gripper a cat of the gripper
we designed this grippers all 3D printed
it weighs about 22.7 grams that can
close within 12 milliseconds upon impact
we use the compliance suspension
mechanism which to reduce the loading
during collision and also increase the
Collision duration compared to a rigid
gripper and I had some videos later
showing this
so how does the gripper work here's a
cutaway of the gripper you have a force
coming in
from the Collision
and there's two parts of the gripper
that's like oops there's two parts
gripper that slides on top of each other
the orange part and the white part it
slides backwards that's your linear com
that's your linear compression a linear
compliance and this relative movement
between the two parts causes a blue
tendon to pull the yellow trigger
upwards I release this to the red block
which has rubber band in there to
provide a potential energy as soon as
this trigger is pulled this red block
accelerates forward and poses green
tendon which is connected through a
bunch of tendon routing to the under
actually finger on the bottom then it
closes like this
and the blue part here you see is a
self-centering ball joint where we build
this exploiting the nature of the
torsion of spring stiffness of a
compliance of a compression spring this
is very similar to for those of you who
play games on your joy-con on your
drawer on your controllers how does your
Droid your joystick always self-centers
after you apply input same principle
here
so now after understanding these things
what we want to move on to is this what
I call the force efficiency region we'll
talk a little bit more about this
so we have this gripper it's time to
bring into a benchtop testing how do we
validate that it actually works first
what we did was we mounted this on a six
axis Force torque sensor ATI right here
and we apply a random force on the top
empirically after doing many many many
trials we can plot this in four space
looks like this so This limit surface in
four space basically represents the
minimum amount of force it needs from
the Collision to trigger the grasping
sequence because everything is friction
in there and the two examples here is
the green Vector pierces through this
bottom limit surface so then the in this
case the grasping sequence will trigger
and the red Vector here does not never
intersect with the surface that means
that force is not going to be able to
trigger a grasping sequence
so now with this sort of force
efficiency region
I want to move over to Velocity
sufficiency region why do we need to do
this because drones in nature is
controlled by velocity whether you give
a position or velocity controlled
it's not too useful when you tell the
Drone hey can you hit the target at two
Newtons in this direction well the Drone
doesn't know how to do that but instead
you tell the Drone okay can you hit it
at this particular velocity within this
velocity envelope yeah sure there's
plenty of algorithms out there right now
can compute a flag trajectory for you so
that's the importance of velocity
sufficiency region but then how do we go
from Force to Velocity
another experimental setup so what we
did here is we built experimental setup
drones mounted on linear rail powered by
a Pneumatic piston so it actually
launches the Drone of the rail and hits
the target drone at the exact moment
because it's controlled by electromagnet
we have a force torque sensor mounted on
the tip of the Drone where the Collision
happens
you do this many times varying the
pressure in the Piston which varies the
velocity gives you this linear
relationship between velocity the exit
velocity of the Min drone and what's the
peak impulse Force we're experiencing I
at the point of collation
so with this we can this can serve as a
translator between force and velocity
space at this point it's time to really
evaluate your design it does your does a
gripper at this point actually solve the
problem
there's a grouper at this point actually
meets the design requirement if not we
have to go through a redesign process if
it does time to go through the flight
control controller so before I send any
videos I want to explain a little bit
more about this velocity sufficiency
region so I'll redefine it here really
quick basically it's a region in
velocity space which gives you the
highest probability of a grasp of
success so I'll break this down a little
bit more let's look at a 2d size easier
doing 2D in X and Y Direction
the lower bound basically is determined
by from the force efficiency region test
is basically if your velocity in that
region you don't have enough Force to
trigger the grasping sequence
the sides are bounded by the gripper
mechanics how much compliance you have
in the angular direction that you all
and Pitch Direction on the gripper
and the size and the top are bounded by
the quadrilateral Dynamics your your
required order is running into another
object in mid-fly the resulting torque
of torque at Force disturbance to the
main drone needs to stay within the
Control Authority your drone cannot
crash after this intended Collision
so this enclosed space right here is the
velocity sufficiency region
so basically it's a combination of
velocities that we can say okay the
Drone should try to hit the target with
these velocity profiles to maximize the
chances of success
the key point I want to point out here
is that this region is not an absolute
but a gradient that means
as you approach as your velocity
conditions approaches the boundary of
this velocity region the probability of
success decreases so there might be some
failure that happens with even if your
velocity is within this region and there
might be some successes in there even if
it's outside this region this is all
probability based
you can repeat the same thing to do for
the XC Direction
then it gives you this
so I explain a little bit more as a
video is playing so we're using a 500
gram drone with the gripper capturing
about 85 gram modified mobile drone
um I have various different velocities
here is about 1.5 meters per second
played at 110 speed and we repeat this
many many times
this is the fastest we have done is 2.7
meters per second
yeah the propeller didn't make it
foreign
so this is uh capturing a relative
velocity basically moving targets
okay so this is for error grasping this
is what we did and why we did it so I
want to move on to the second part of
this talk is let's talk about Planetary
Exploration
so here I have a picture of the
Curiosity
and well the proposed our new robot
design is called richbot It's a small
robot with exceptional reach for rough
terrain and this is a collaboration
between our lab bdml and ASL over at
over at Aero astral and collaborators
Stephanie eudick who's a student in the
in ASL and Carlo who was an exchange
student in our lab and now he's a PhD
student at Berkeley
so what is Rich bar the concept is a
small mobile robot that uses Long Reach
to navigate really difficult terrains
and interact with the environment
it has a really really large workspace
ensures more accessible grasping spots
and and faster Traverse across certain
areas
so what's the problem here you see a
state of our climbing robot here is the
Lemur through here you see on the bottom
just like you and me also when we go to
the climbing wall I always feel like I
could use a longer arm once I'm on the
wall can I reach the next hold it's
limited by the length of my arm but what
now what if your arm is actually
extendable like this now that suddenly
you have a lot larger workspace you can
search you might not run into desk spots
where you saw that you could get to the
Target by suddenly in certain parts
Midway through the trajectory you
realize you can't reach the next
grasping spot
so this is our proposed solution we use
repurposed extendable Booms for mobile
manipulation to achieve extreme reach
the enabling technology here is these
space booms they collapse really just
imagine them as 3D tape measures
and this is actually a thing built by
roadcore used to deploy a camera in
space outside the space station they
compact really small and then they fold
out in a 3D 3D thing just exactly like a
3D tape measure they're really strong
intention so you can pull on them as
hard as you can just like a tape measure
but with any other Force conditions
they're easily blockable so they can go
through Buckle fairly easily so these
are the extendable booms we're proposing
to use as arms
so we have a lot of research pillar like
this is a Brand New Concept we're trying
to propose there's a lot of things we
need to investigate and my uh my
colleagues Stephanie mainly focuses on
trajectory planning and the trajectory
optimization of this but today I want to
Mo mostly focus on two here lightweight
surface grasping Solutions
so if we're talking about grasping
Solutions the first thing is what are we
trying to grasp a lot of these lava
under the nasogram the the objective is
for us to study the feasibility of a
bridge bar to explore a Subterranean
cave on Mars these lava tube caves on
Mars and we're looking to grasp services
like this lava rocks and the technology
we use for grasping these lava rocks is
something called microspine it's
bio-inspired it is sort of inspired from
it's inspired from insects and such as
cockroaches unfortunately cockroaches
are really really good at climbing
vertical walls and the reason why they
can do that is that they have these hard
spines at their leg it catches on the
small asparities onto seemingly smooth
walls to you and me but it's enough to
give them the kitchen they need to climb
any a lot of the surfaces that we think
is smooth with the same principle we use
these need almost needles on the bottom
here you see that use the same principle
that caches on these small asparities on
Rock surfaces to give us adhesion so
that's just a quick overview of the
technology we're using we have this
entire
New Concept
of course we're not just going to go out
there we don't have the money either or
the time or if we don't even know if
this thing is going to work to build a
whole system so we need to start
somewhere so what we start is to build a
planar prototype low-cost planar
prototype you see here is a planar Ridge
bot that rolls on four bearings that's
free floating on a flat surface and like
I was hinting earlier what's the 2D
cheap alternative to these expensive
space booms tape measure so we motorized
these tape measure to extend
and retract
and each of these tape measure unit arm
is mounted on Servo so that you can
rotate pivot the shoulder joint as well
so it does all the basic functionality
of proof of concept for reach block
it has this micro span gripper which
I'll go in slightly more in detail after
this I want to show the sequence real
quick extends out it identifies a
grasping spot it extends out it uses a
passively triggered gripper so all you
have to do is run it into it it triggers
it stored energy and then you can pull
on it real quick to give you this
adhesion so now you can move your robot
to that location
so this is one of the first uh tests we
did with reach bot
with playing that rich spot
and now with this capability you can do
a lot more interesting things such as
now you have a free floating robot and
the gripper resets
and you can do a lot more interesting
things
you have a free floating platform that
you can just move around but now with
these grippers you can actually anchor
yourself to the environment and now
you're able to move an object that's way
heavier than previously what you're able
to do
and this is a simple demonstration of
that and now you manipulate to a Target
location that you want okay we can let
that go
and we can do how does robot move this
is a very simple case scenario where you
as long as you maintain tension inside
of your arms you can translate between
multiple anchor points like this
so the whole system will look like this
this is a demonstration we put together
is that you are
anchored into a certain spot and you're
scanning around you're looking for the
next grasping spot you identify this as
a potential grasping spot you extend
your arm out touches it it activates a
grip confirms that it's there it's
attached
and then you release
and you pull yourself towards the target
yeah so the 2D gripper here so this
whole robot was built as a proof of
concept to convince ourselves and other
people that this concept works so for
the gripper we just need something quick
and dirty that it works so we have these
micro spine groupers on individual
suspensions and we have a passively
triggered gripper here we use a
passively trigger gripper because we
really need to minimize the amount of
weight we put at the end of the boom
normally it doesn't seem too much weight
but as you increase the weight of the
boom and they extend all the way out
maybe four or three four five meters
then becomes a huge weight inertia you
are swinging around and you can buckle
your boom easily so we had to really
minimize the weight but we just built
something that works but now the uh
we're trying to convince ourselves this
thing works then we need to move into 3D
how do we actually build a 3D gripper so
it's with the same training style that
we what I talked about before what we
where do we have to start we had to
start with modeling so first we had to
understand the spine surface interaction
their law goes goes uh goes down here
because the rock surface is stochastic
so everything is probability based so
all these all these uh forces are
dependent on a lot of things like spine
tip radius surface roughness material
strength a lot of these things
once we understand the surface and this
is ongoing research so this is um once
we understand the surface and surface
spine surface interaction then we'll say
okay let's go with the three finger
gripper now you can write all your
kinematics of it try to come try to come
with fourth equilibrium and contact
conditions try to write equations for
the whole entire gripper for dynamic
Statics and Dynamics
and after all this it can give you
basically a wrench that you can apply at
the wrist so that's the thing we're
after it's basically how strong are
these grippers attach the Rock and how
hard we can pull on things
and you can go through things
everything's probabilistic you can go
through a multicolor simulation and it
gives you something like this a fourth
limit so it gives you a force uh it
gives you a limit surface in four space
basically saying given the design given
the parameters of the gripper how much
force can you reasonably uh get all the
gripper once it's firmly attached to a
surface
once we have the model we go ahead and
build the gripper and we have uh it's
still working through multiple
iterations and working on all the Kinks
of it once they have a gripper what do
we do next so we haven't done this yet
but this is the next step is what we
have a model we have a prototype the
same flow logic then we had to test it
in a lab setting environment we had to
do a bunch of lab tests pull tests on it
and try to make sure that you can
achieve the desired grasping that force
that we want after that after we
validate the model we either have to go
through a redesign process and make sure
that we hit the target the design
requirement or if it's good enough then
let's go test in the field uh testing
the field so right now we're scoping out
this is a lava tube actually I'm a hobby
desert that we're gonna go later this
quarter try to scope out and build a
partial reach ball there so that we can
show the whole system working of
scanning the area try to grasp uh um
part of the rock try to pull on it to a
certain degree and see to validate our
model
so that's what we're here and I think
that's the last slide I have and I just
want to say thank you real quick for my
lab and all the funding sources
supporting this project and I think I'll
take questions I think that's about 21
minutes I'll take some questions yeah
foreign
so you said this robot's purpose was for
uh exploring yeah and I'm wondering
based off of the movement and how fast
can we go but what's the reasonable uh
estimate how much area you think this
robot can explore it just seems quite
slow yeah so that's a good question so I
think um I I think it depends you know a
lot of things the current
scenario we're looking at is martian you
know you look at different like
planetary gravity means that how heavy
does the robot to be how long can you
extend the boom before it buckles so it
really depends on what gravity region
you were talking about here
a good thing about NASA is that when you
talk about these planetary explorations
They Don't Really Care how fast you go
and you compare it to the Baseline of
what we're comparing right now a rigid
link robot
it should be able to one it has two
distinct advantages one is that it can
reach a lot more grasping spot at a
certain point two
to go from one side of the room to the
other if my leg is twice as long I need
to take to twice a little steps towards
fewer steps from one room to another so
we get that working for us as well
so it's uh but if you're talking about
another application we're thinking about
reach bot is for space
um
space station servicing but then that
that actually becomes easier because
that's in microgravity then you don't
really have to worry about part of the
gravity your boom extending out nearly
as much the whole thing buckling so that
you have even longer reach then you
might be able to go from point A to
point B just in one step so it all
really depends